bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
cadre somptueux sur comment la rade de
marseille
souvenez-vous il ya quelques semaines
dans l'émission elodie jeune maman de
deux enfants avait ému toute l'équipe
touche pas à mon poste
mj motor france et l'équipe tmp se sont
associés pour lui offrir le nouveau mgs
nsv suv 100% électrique je tremble
nous allons découvrir ensemble son
nouveau véhicule
[Musique]
bonjour elodie bonjour bienvenue
je voyage est aussi super bon allez pour
vous à découvrir qu elle émettra fin
magnifique
ça y est là le rêve devient réalité trop
trop trop contente a vraiment changé
notre vie parce que j'avais une voiture
donc je suis extrêmement reconnaissante
te propose de le découvrir à l'intérieur
allez allez c'est parti avant de sortir
une toute dernière surprise
elodie le shérif et ça y est c'est le
jour j je voulais te laisser un petit
message vidéo pour fêter la remise des
clés de cette superbe voiture alors
technique c'est la mgts devait ton
histoire à nous à coucher tout c'est ma
chérie je voulais juste dire que je
pense fort à toi à tes deux enfants enzo
et thiméo et on espère que la voiture
elle te plaît tu vas kiffer dedans tu
mets la clim tu mets le chauffage c'est
une clim réversible
c'est à dire que tu peux mettre le chaud
le froid tu peux aussi ouvrir les
fenêtres
je veux tu kiffes voilà avec tes enfants
je t'aime format elodie et prenez soin
de vos toute la famille si un jour
pourrait me déposer quelque part bien
sûr en tarif à ça m'arrange salé ma
chérie merci franchement m'attendais pas
du tout j'adore que c'est de la torre
trop je m'attendais pas du tout le film
parce que
ça va changer notre musique en fête et
c'est génial puis ça me touche
énormément ce message on a plus que le
nom soit oui c'est aussi assez
impressionnant sa famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup y perd débouche souvent sur les
joues
c'est la tienne
aventure jeu
pouvoir partir
oui
ah ouais pouvoir vivre normalement non
merci du fond du coeur cyril et toute
l'équipe de tpm paix parce que
un formidable
c'est énormément
il y à une gym au tort c'est plus qu'un
rêve là c'est vraiment on n'aurait
jamais stéréo temps ça va
ému mais ça m'a vraiment changé notre
vie et on est super mal à nous rejoindre
vraiment le goût de vivre et la liberté
de pouvoir aller où on veut et de vivre
de super moments avec mes enfants et et
on est vraiment éternellement
reconnaissants quoi vraiment
[Musique]